sure playgrounds are supposed to be a
little risky to challenge kids but what
happens when they're downright
treacherous nails Fire Heights and
broken-down rides are all revealed here
just wait until you see number one
showing why one ride was open only a
month before the lives lost counted too
high
have you been to the things before if
not hit the subscribe button below and
give this video a big thumbs up now here
are ten most dangerous playgrounds for
kids Alpine Coaster Tennessee the Smoky
Mountain Alpine Coaster in Pigeon Forge
Tennessee has brought kids an adult
alike to try their crazy slide it's the
longest downhill track in the whole
entire United States and their slogan is
ride the hill and fill the thrill
more like fear for your life in 2016 in
just one month there were three serious
injuries reported that could have ended
much worse WSMV spoke to the victims
about the injuries who said they never
expected to be leaving on a stretcher
another lady who was ejected from the
small seed of the track said it felt
like being in a car crash so how is the
Alpine Coaster different than regular
slides and rides it is a set of downhill
tracks where the rider controls their
own speed however there is nothing that
keeps the cars from colliding or from
going too fast the cards get up to 30
miles per hour and whizzed on the side
of a mountain the ride recommends
leaving 80 feet apart from each but that
didn't stop the third accident in one
month before the carts collided the
riders were left alone for some time in
pain and calling for help in a
TripAdvisor comment a woman says it has
the possibility of critical back neck
spine and head injuries sounds like one
ride that will be sitting out on
Hiawatha playground Seattle into the
time machine everyone we're taking a
trip let's head back in time to the
early 20th century even before World War
one in 1912 a playground in Seattle
called Hiawatha play field cause
children to find their thrills from high
heights and dangerous plummets in 1986
the City of Seattle declared the park
and landmark but before that there were
some serious boo-boos
first off there was no health and safety
regulations to protect the kids the
structure stood as high as a building
made of long thin poles that kids would
climb on and if he fell through there
wasn't anything to grab hold of the
slice may have been the most innovative
part of the structure if you can call it
that it was too long poles with an arm's
length apart that the children would
prop themselves in between and slide
down using their armpits painful maybe
but thrilling a definite yes the park
sure did lead to some injuries but it
also led to learning by trial and error
for the young uns
now there is talk about playgrounds
being too safe and not allowing kids
make the same mistakes do you want
playgrounds to be more of a thrill than
light fun Riverside playground Southwest
Sydney let's take a trip around the
world to great sunny Australia in
southwest Sydney the Riverside
playground may not look dangerous at
first glance but it causes more harm
than some of the more overtly dangerous
parks can you guess what it is the
reason why this seemingly innocent
playground is a major threat will
surprise you it's the lack of trees that
are causing the harm in the sunny and
ever hot Sydney the rays beat down so
hard that it heats the slides up to
burning temperatures and it isn't just
burning your bottom it's also a cause of
overheating and sunburns so why doesn't
the city just put up some trees and fix
this invisible problem well it seems
that the main issue holding the city
back from saving those from heatstroke
and red skin is money seems like the
city's priorities aren't quite right
this is only one of the many new parks
in Australia that have this problem the
playgrounds are too new to have grown
the needed shade for Sun safety they are
too young so to speak at least with this
problem there are solutions of sunscreen
hats and water to keep the fun going all
day long - via to Russia this infamous
park has been questioned to be the most
dangerous children's park in existence
we're not sure we go that far but it
definitely has shockingly dangerous
devices without a name it is located in
- via to Russia just outside Moscow and
appears to be extremely old the
contraptions almost look more like
medieval torture devices than a kids
playground all the pieces seem to be
made of scrap metal which is all rusting
if this wasn't enough the actual
playground itself
filled with hazards two men posted a
video on YouTube as they explored the
park they went around testing out each
part with harmful results first off he
strapped his feet into one contraption
that spins in circles he became
instantly dislodged and had to hold
himself on so he wouldn't fall and hit
his head on the metal ring below in
another test he sits inside a tire which
is meant to be a swing and is turned
upside down there are plenty of ominous
places to fall out of things pinch
fingers or hit your head on a hard rusty
metal not even mentioning the overall
creepy look of the park this place is no
playground for little ones Luna Park
friends a ride is scary enough soaring
through the air at impossible heights
and plummeting back down to the ground
will definitely get the adrenaline
pumping imagine being on a ride that
actually broke while you were on it if
that doesn't get the fear in you going
nothing will that is exactly what
happened to the passengers of the Fifth
Element ride the ride is presented on
the theme parks website as for the
kamikazes located at Luna Park and all
ages amusement playground in southern
France the accident occurred when the
slingshot ride bolted up into the air
and as the capsule came back down the
cable snapped suspending the passengers
dangerously inside a witness who
captured a video of the event said that
the riders were trapped for over an hour
before being rescued by firefighters
when the cable broke the capsule swung
around hitting one of the side poles
that held up the ride the independence
reported the 24 year old woman suffered
large bruises and a broken leg after
finally being rescued a broken leg seems
like a lucky escape from what could have
been a sure end so let's be honest
things could have been much worse
the slingshot rides are prevalent at
many amusement parks which begs the
question if they're all as dangerous as
this one talk about dangerous
playgrounds for everyone are any
thrill-seekers going to check this crazy
slingshot outs grand canyon swing the
name says it all yup it's a swing right
over the Grand Canyon
well technically just around the corner
from the Grand Canyon at Glenwood
caverns at Binger Park if you're afraid
of heights this definitely wouldn't be
the ride for you or really anybody the
only thing
this structure from following the 6090
three-foot plummet into the canyon below
there's a couple metal beams that don't
seem too sturdy sure it's stuck in the
ground on the edge of the canyon but
what is that cliff broke off or the
screws pulled out of the grounds we all
like to believe the people building
these are careful but after so many
years these structures do get older the
ride lasts 60 seconds all of which you
will be contemplating your morality the
dangers are countless on this big swing
you could tumble down into the depth
below if your safety harness had one
glitch thrill-seekers from around the
globe come to ride the swing and kids
must be at least 48 inches to tackle
their fear of heights
other than the long arm that swings you
out there isn't much stopping the
impending doom it has been called the
ultimate white-knuckle ride Metro
reported one van sane in 7 words the
scariest bride I have ever done what is
the scariest ride or playground you've
been to share in the comments below
blazing fury Dollywood we couldn't have
thought of a better name ourselves but
Dollywood owned by ultimate country star
Dolly Parton yep that's right she owns
an amusement park we'll say it because
we know you're all thinking it it's
weird
however this park isn't as hunky-dory as
the name cracks it up to be on one of
their apparently child safe rides
entitled blazing fury a major injury was
sustained that resulted in a massive
lawsuit the ride is described as an
out-of-control fire just minutes away
from engulfed in the 1880s town yes you
heard right a man brought his family to
the park and sustained major brain
damage from the ride he is suing Dolly
Parton productions for twenty million
dollars it is a complicated case due to
the injuries but the park did not give
proper warning to the dangers the park
and the blazing fury Tour de France are
still open to this day so if you want to
visit a playground where rides and risk
could go hand-in-hand you can visit this
one today but we recommend you avoiding
a lawsuit and keeping that smart noggin
of yours intact
maybe dolly should have stuck to her
singing career and not ventured off into
children's amusements adventure
playground in Berkeley California
located in Berkeley California this
playground has been
written up as one of the ten best
playgrounds by National Geographic now
that's saying a lot so how did this park
in the pond our list of the most
dangerous would it be the nails lying
around on purpose or could it be these
slippery surfaces or even the zip line
what about the hammer in the saw this
park is touted as so incredibly great
because it gives children the
responsibility to build things and be
cautious when kids are confronted with
age-appropriate risks they are actually
more careful than when they can see they
are more advanced than what is given as
cool that the concept of this is there
are still dirty nails lying in the sand
sturdy shoes are a must but why not just
remove the nails the image of someone
accidentally stepping on one of those is
hashtag cringe-worthy on the City of
Berkeley website they say the park
includes elements of earth fire water
and lots of creative material as fun as
it sounds is it really safe what do you
think about this park that opened up in
1979 and Garner's so much praise would
you want to go play on it
cement land this is a playground kids
can no longer get to unless they break
in this Park isn't open to the public
with a chain-link fence surrounding the
perimeters but cement land still
attracts those risky kids that want to
sneak in and see what it's all about
sure the name is enticing but it doesn't
sound like much fun cement Lin was
designed by Bob castle II who had turned
the former Missouri Portland cement co
into a park however since he died in
2011 the future of the park has been
undecided for a number of reasons one of
them being safety so how did Bob pass
away well the answer should really be
why the park remains off-limits to the
little ones Bob passed away in a
bulldozing accident while working along
the property in September 2011 some of
the dangers to the park are the nearby
river it's all made of scrap metals and
it's near an active railway on social
media many people post about the site
one photo even shows what looks to be an
unstable rusted metal bridge with no
railing we understand why nature is
reclaiming this and that for now
middlin will remain more a piece of art
than a place for children to play cannon
ball oof New Jersey the cannon ball loop
sounds like the type of fun we all want
to have it's how you hear the mortality
rate on this bad boy
the Cannonball loop was opened for just
one month in the 1980s before being shut
down
located in Vernon New Jersey at the
action park it garnered the nicknames of
accident Park and class action park
which seemed to be accurate after
hearing what goes on
they had a count of six fatalities
caused by the loop and drowning the
Cannonball loop was a waterslide that
did an upside-down 360 then shot you out
the other side some people would get
stuck in the loop others who made it
around would smack hard into the
opposite side of the loop there are
countless reports of life-threatening
injuries including concussions and
missing teeth the park still maintained
it's fun factor through other rides that
the Cannonball loop has never opened
again Mental Floss published an article
hinting at the fact that the treacherous
waterslide may see the light of day
again the park is attempting a new
version that is safe and fun so despite
six deaths 110 injuries including 45
head injuries and 10 fractures kids may
actually be able to ride this crazy
thing again will you be attempting the
Cannonball loop if it ever returns let
us know in the comments do you want to
visit any of these crazy dangerous
playgrounds let us know your thoughts
down below thanks for watching 10 most
dangerous playgrounds for kids on the
things Channel
see you next time
[Music]